تقرير ان اسره لي بعنوان انذار احمر حذر
من حرب وشيكه بين الصين واستراليا وسيبدا
بمجرد ان تعلن بكين الهجوم على تايوان في
التفاصيل ذكرت صحيفه سيدني مورنينج محذره
الاستراليين من انهم يواجهون خطر الحرب مع
الصين في غضون ثلاث سنوات في حين ان
البلاد غير مستعده لاي صراع مع القوه
الاسيويه العظمى الصاعده التحذير جاء على
لسان لجنه من خبراء الامن القومي جمعتها
الصحيفه وتوصلت الى ان الحرب قد تاتي في
وقت مبكر من عام 2026 مع غزو الصين نقطه
اشتعال الصراع المحتدم في المحيط الهادئ
لانه استراليا ستجد نفسها في خضم الحرب
على اعتبار احتوائها قواعد امريكيه
وبالتالي واشنطن ستستخدم الاراضي
الاستراليه للدفاع عن تايوان هذا واطلق
الخبراء في تقريرهم التحذير الانذار
الاحمر الذي يعدوه بمثابه جرس انذار كبير
القوات المسلحه الاستراليه والامه ككل
محذرين من ان بلادهم غير مستعده
[موسيقى]